listen and understand that pandemic is
out there
it can't be bargained with it can't be
reasoned with
it doesn't feel pity remorse or fear and
it absolutely will not stop no one else
won't stop what Sara Disney News you see
that so angrily
avatar and Avengers films being
re-released in China patty Jenkins out
why she passed on Thor the dark world
Michael Bohen Caston Mandalorian season
2 that's all we're gonna talk about
today let's get into it first story on
the agenda avatar versus endgame once
again apparently in China they're gonna
be releasing some movies as a sign that
it's getting better which gives some
hope because apparently things are
getting a lot better in China where all
this actually did start China that is
the big question is coming up again and
will a Betar beat out endgame in terms
of box office will become the number one
reigning box office champion and game is
currently number one in the world Kevin
Feige did say at comic-con when you
adjust for inflation avatar still is
number one because avatar came out many
years before looking at box office mojo
numbers have pulled in front of me
currently endgame is at two billion
seven hundred ninety seven million eight
hundred thousand dollars avatar is a two
billion seven hundred ninety million
four hundred thirty nine thousand
dollars on the dot no nothing in the
hundreds there here's the big ticker
I feel like avatar actually has a good
chance at beating it even though endgame
Hatton has made more money domestically
and game made significantly less money
international wise China is the biggest
box office outside of the u.s. it seems
like Chinese audiences probably
gravitate more towards avatar and
they're not just gonna be re-releasing
endgame alone they're gonna be releasing
all the Avengers movies maybe people
might be like I'll just wait for any
game or they might start with the
Avengers first one and then be and I
don't want to keep watching the rest
I don't know how Chinese audiences
actually work when it comes to this but
looking at the number
here more people internationally and a
large chunk of that is China tuned in
for avatar versus endgame seems like
avatar has a good shot of reclaiming the
throne with that 15 minutes less run
time you can get a few more screenings
in the end games so that's also a small
factor to consider but I think you're
probably right
well and also you know endgame just did
come out last year played in the
theaters for a long time whereas avatar
we haven't had a chance to see that in
the movie theaters for quite a long time
maybe people will be more inclined out
of re-releases to go check out avatar
because I'm sure a lot of people have
also been rewatching endgame at home
already
whereas avatar people probably have a
watch in awhile I feel like if it was a
USB release and definitely be endgame by
the fact that it's China could bump and
game down and number two it could and we
also have James Cameron's for other
avatar movies on the way so it has that
extra boost of like oh we're gonna
revisit this world maybe soon yeah so
people might want to go refresh on
avatar see that experience again yeah
what do you guys think do you think
avatar will actually outdo endgame in
China leave your thoughts down below
those are the movies that people love
let's talk about them see you movie that
seems to be the most disliked but well
corner recent bullets actually Iron Man
3 apparently rhythm just kind of strange
to me but apparently Thor the dark world
original director attached patty Jenkins
spoke about why she left the project
here's the quote I did not believe that
I could make a good movie out of script
that they were planning on doing burn
burn I think it would have been a huge
deal it would have looked like it was my
fault it would have looked like oh my
god this woman directed it and she
missed all these things Thor was the one
time in my career where I really felt
like do this with another director and
it's not going to be a big deal and
maybe they'll understand it and love it
more than I do
you can't do movies you don't believe in
the only reason to do which would be to
prove to people that I could but it
wouldn't have proved anything if I
didn't succeed I don't think that I
would have got another chance and so I'm
super grateful he makes a solid point
she does make a solid point it would
have been the first MCU film helmed by a
female director all the blame definitely
would have gone to her cuz it would have
been a lot of talk surrounding the fact
that patty Jenkins female director
is helming this movie I think
instantaneously a lot of people
definitely would have put the blame on
her and I think it is the wise move if
you genuinely feel like you don't have
something to offer that could elevate
the material or make it a good thing I
think generally speaking writer director
or even actor back out of the project if
you really don't think you can do a good
job or you know you don't feel like
you're up for the challenge so I think
she made the right call evidently she
did considering the response that movie
got I just saw a tweet from I think
Collider the other day that had a bunch
of numbers and it was like you can't
rank all the MCU films because they're
different need to have their own merits
and then the very last one is this Thor
the dark world I think it was screen
junkies or screen junkies maybe yeah I
can definitely respect the long game
that she played on that because yeah if
you don't feel like you have something
special to bring in something that
really stirs you up about a project then
you probably should pass it on to
somebody else leading that in to Wonder
Woman I think it very much made sense
for her because also yeah it's the
sequel and luckily she dodged the sequel
that started kind of a souring of the
MCU flavor during that phase yeah so
yeah big respect to patty Jenkins on
that and also good on her for knowing
the landscape because I do think that
I'm sure while a lot of people want to
argue over that it probably would have
come down to her for the blame it
probably wouldn't have been deserved so
I'm glad that that also didn't happen
yeah all right guys well with that news
story out of the way do you think patty
Jenkins would have done a better job
then I want to say Alan Taylor yeah
better get it in the game of thrones
dray yeah not Alan Ball no blood so much
more love making version of Thor anyway
let's move on mandalorian season 2 news
we already got a word that rosario
Dawson is ahsoka tano and now we have a
report here from th part The Hollywood
Reporter Michael Biehn terminators Kyle
Reese a dude in the abyss Johnny Ringo
in in tombstone he is going to be in the
mandalorian season 2 I'm excited for
this because the Mandalorian strikes
this balance of sci fi obviously and
Western he is
CEL in both categories so getting an
actor like Michael Biehn who usually
does like B movies now a lot of shimmery
schlocky like material a lot of stuff he
produces with his wife he's on the Cameo
app too let's go follow him over there
get yourself a shout out yeah I'm
excited for them I think Michael Biehn
is always a very engaging actor to watch
even when he's like over the top I
really enjoy his performances always and
so I think that having him included in
the cast I imagine would probably just
be a one episode guest star role because
some characters in the mandalorian are
reoccurring feel like all most of them
get a shot at being reoccurring for the
most part that are usually just in one
episode also bill burr is expected to
return for his season around where they
got where Gina Carano Carl Weathers our
returning bill burr turning out I think
is really exciting because I loved him
in the Mandalorians great yeah I think
that's like a fan favorite role that
they were just like oh we gotta bring
him back so I got a question to you Star
Wars nuts out there for Michael Biehn to
be cast in the mandalorian season - is
there a character from Star Wars Canon
that you're hoping he will portray the
fact that they got ahsoka tano in there
is there a character from rebels or
Clone Wars that you're hoping he will do
or do you just want to be an original
character - the same way bill burrs
character was just an original Kari
leave your thoughts down below I'm
excited for a Michael Biehn underrated
actor this will sky rocketed oh and
perfect for this world yeah yeah alright
guys well those are the most interesting
news out of Disney today half the movie
they're owned yep Batman and Wonder
Woman delayed we all know that we all
saw it coming but if you haven't done so
already subscribe to the reel rejects
click the notification well again notify
would never got a youtube video up last
but not least let's end this with a
Austin Snyder no Austin Snyder is an
aspiring teacher whose biggest
fascination actually deals with history
specifically ancient Rome and Greece I
decided to fill in some quotes from
movies that take place in ancient Rome
and Greece and you have to guess which
movies these are from some are obvious
some are more of a deep cut this one at
a time in traditional ancient Rome and
Greece accents British imagine a king
who fights his own battles
wouldn't that be a
Austin Schneider tonight Austin
Schneider we dine in Hell yeah what is
her name 41 is it Austin Schneider the
frost sometimes it makes the blade stick
like Austin Snyder's thick Hotel you
Austin Schneider and the rest of the
barbarians set fire to my library
prepare for glory
Austin Schneider let them know men did
this and one of those men was Austin
Schneider for a moment let Austin enjoy
a calm sea and a fresh breeze and each
other have 24 hours to get rid of this
bozo Austin Schneider well the entire
plan I've been planning goes up in smoke
and you are wearing his merchandise my
name is Maximus Austin Schneider
Meridius you are free now Austin
Schneider this is sparta and Austin
Schneider yeah yeah
you